السلطات الصوماليه ضاقت ذرعا من حركه
الشباب المرتبطه بالقاعده والتي تشنها
هجمات ارهابيه على البلاد منذ سنوات
وقديشه اطلقت عمليه عسكريه هي الاكبر منذ
ظهور الحركه وذلك من اجل القضا عليها
العمليه ستستهلك اساسا عناصر الحركه سيما
المقاتلين منهم هي اذا حرب شامله تشنها
السلطات الصوماليه على هذه الحركه
المنتشره في الكثير من مناطق البلاد
ويعدوا اقليم جوبا الوسطى الوحيده التي
تسيطر عليه الحركه بالكامل فهو اكثر اقليم
يضم غابات تتحسن فيها قيادات الحركه وياتي
اقليم جوبا همم السفلي في جوبلاند همم في
المرتبه الثانيه من حيث تشعر مسلح الحركه
هيا تسيطر على نحو ال 60 بالمائه منه فيما
يحتل اقليم هيران بولايه هيرشبيل المرتبه
الثالثه